right-hander jacob degrom
yeah and he's got great command of his
fastball he owns the upper part of the
strike zone you see the numbers in nine
starts
sliders down and into lefties they
haven't been able to catch up with this
fastball he adds it to change up
and the first three innings matty he
usually relies on that fastball the
first time through the batting order we
see if
see if he does the same thing tonight
the next one-two pitch coming to fam and
he got him to chase a slider
one gone here's fernando tantes is three
and two to tatis and he strikes him out
as well
oh man he just hits the ground running
he is not a staff ace that needs an
inning or two to get into the flow of
the game
he comes right at you and look at the
location of this pitch
knee-high outside corner too close to
take it's
jay cronenworth after back-to-back
strikeouts have the fans
every bit invested in tonight
cronenworth makes contact
it's a pop for lindor and it's a breezy
start to the night
for the two-time cy young award winner
and they take their chances with a
former
cy young award winner blake snell won
the award in the american league in
2018. the 28 year old
first year padre making his 13th start
in a san diego uniform tonight
here's francisco lindor now had a 5 for
16
series against the padres last weekend
at petco park
part of that kind of improved stage of
his season
sharply hit but right to machado to kim
for one an
easy double play yeah hit well but right
at the wrong guy
manny machado one of the best at third
base and then they're able to turn it
pretty easily and get
lindor by a few strides back to work
it's machado myers and profar middle of
the order here for san diego
2-1 pitch to machado a fly ball down to
center
kevin pilar is there and there is one
away for degrom
from owen two to a full count here's the
payoff
and he made him chase that same slider
did not
throw him a single fastball yeah look at
the tight spin on that breaking ball to
a hitter it looks like it's going to be
a strike
and is the case in most strikeouts
they're actually out of the strike zone
by the time
they get to the plate 02 to pro fire
and it's popped up
18 consecutive scoreless innings for
jacob degrom
and counting an ending and a half gone
tonight six
up six down with three strikeouts as
degrom has
run his consecutive scoreless ending
streak to 18
longest active streak of its kind in the
big leagues
jam shot off the fists lindor makes an
easy time of it for route number two
got him 100 mile an hour gas up around
the shoulders five strikeouts in three
perfect innings for jacob degrom fam
struck out to start the ball game
2-2 and he struck out again six
for degrom looks like a strike till you
swing at it
you see the ball kind of tucked back in
his hand and it has a little
reverse spin screw ball spin and even
that pitch is in the low 90s
one gone now for fernando tatis jr also
a strikeout victim tonight
he wanted the slider and he strikes out
tatis with it for the second time
tonight
seven strikeouts for degrom three and
two thirds into the game
he has not allowed a base runner through
the first three and two thirds
and he struck out the side in the fourth
best opportunity for either side to play
to run tonight
two runners aboard with one away
scoreless tie last to the fourth
tan he loses him on ball four he's
taking way
too much time right now two delivered
study long you study wrong
vr at third and then after back-to-back
walks
mccann and alonso make up the bases
loaded
dominic smith is grounded into three
double plays this year there's a
comebacker for snell to carratini for
the out at the plate
and they turn the double play in and out
of trouble in the fourth
seventh pitch of the at-bat
another slider and it's bounced past the
second baseman for a base hit
first base runner of the game for san
diego
he laid off a couple of tough pitches
and then just fought that one off and
got rewarded with a base hit
but that was actually alonso that he
sent that ball passed pete was way off
the bag
myers runs throw to second is in time to
get him
nice throw by mccann getting out of the
chute lindor right there on the bag
and make a nice sweep tag
two and one the counts of profar he pops
it up
it looks like vr's got to play lost
bucket of balls in the process so he's
in scoring position now for billy
mckinney who jumps on the first pitch
and that's a fair ball that's going to
bring in pilar back to back doubles
and the skunks finally out of the box
one nothing new york
mckinney gets rewarded a little hanging
breaking ball because all he wanted to
do there was pull the ball to the right
side
but a flat breaking ball from snell
kenny gets the barrel to it
and another double you got the pitcher
coming up right now so they figured well
they can chase it but this is not your
ordinary
hitting pitcher machado now even with
the bag at third and the two strike
pitch to degrom a base hit it to left
mckinney scores here's peraza three
nothing mets jacob degrom what can't you
do
they've just taken cy young futures off
the board
at every sports book on the globe boy i
was some at bat
breaking ball outside to ground and he
hit it that way by design
see the infield end just trying to make
contact jacob degrom has now
driven in nine runs he has allowed
seven one out for victor caratini
10 strikeouts for jacob degrom tonight
and that's how he puts away lefty see
down and in above the knees is a great
pitch to hit
but down and in below the knees when it
looks like a strike and you swing over
it that's perfect pitch
o'grady gives that one a ride to deep
right
best hit ball of the night miguel castro
a second year met takes over on the
mound the first
out of the bullpen for jacob degram
whose night is done
with 10 strikeouts and six one-hit
scoreless innings
this was jacob degrom when he was
removed from the game after the sixth
inning
with the mets trainer well i'm glad they
got that shot because that explains it
fernando tatis jr has also struck out
twice tonight
there's a base hit and perhaps more as
it gets past
smith into left field and fernando tatis
junior wheels into second with a one out
double
jake cronin worth with a drive to right
field
and the padres are right back in this
one
jacob degrom hasn't been out of the game
for more than five minutes
and san diego is back to within a run
man you got a guy like that your horse
you just can't take for granted you're
going to win the game three nothing
that pitch was middle middle look they
got the medallion on him
this year he's ratcheted up to a new
level 348 with runners in scoring
position
popped him up
mccann finishes off the night
biggest crowd of the year at city field
and what a treat they had in store for
them tonight